i remember like getting on a flight at
five in the morning from toronto to go
to new york to do the test
i just kind of remembered that whole day
being like you know trying to
keep it all together because i knew how
important it was for me and
uh you know thankfully two days after
that i got a call from kevin feige
saying that i got the part
yes in the new issue of entertainment
weekly simu looks back on the call that
changed his life
taking him from canadian sitcom actor to
international movie star
i thought i could change my name start a
new life
but inside the magazine he reveals that
fateful call came at a stressful time on
set
of kim's convenience what do you think
i don't know earlier the same day he had
an argument over
a line in the show he felt played into a
negative stereotype
he says quote it was terrifying i was on
the verge of tears
it was actually a really really rough
day last month cemu shared a since
deleted facebook post describing a
problematic workplace on set of the cbc
comedy he pointed to the show's
overwhelmingly white writer's room
days later his co-star jean yoon tweeted
that certain story lines were overtly
racist thankfully though the behind the
scenes drama didn't put a damper on
seamless dream
becoming a reality it happened so fast
and my brain
still hasn't quite processed all of it
but it's the it's the greatest journey
man it's
it's really been awesome chongqing the
legend of the ten rings opens september
3rd
and it's marvel's first film with an
asian league i told my men
they wouldn't be able to kill you if
they tried
glad i was right the whole journey is
learning how to live life on his own
terms and to escape from the shadow of
his father and for those of us that are
asian-american or even just you know any
any immigrant household where our
parents come from another country and
and
in us they put in all of their hopes and
dreams of of what they want
for us to accomplish you know that
that's a familiar feeling for all of us